Borders is back and this time I went to
Colombia this country of about 50
million people actually feels like a lot
of different countries because the
landscapes and the cultures are so
different depending on where you go you
can never cover all the stories in one
country but I was able to assemble
plants with most interesting things I
think are happening in Colombia there is
a crisis at this border and I went to go
see what's happening with the many
refugees that are coming from Venezuela
into Colombia and help for Mia's hanpan
and then I went out into some of the
deepest jungle I'd ever been in to
explore Colombia's cocaine economy which
is based entirely on this one leaf the
coca plant oh and I got to see some
hippos during my trip which was kind of
weird I also got to go up to the
beautiful city of cartegena up in the
northern part of Colombia to look into a
subject that I've never looked into
before music and dance so over the next
few weeks and they start releasing these
episodes as always unboxes YouTube
channel and on our Facebook page I hope
you like them hope you learn something
new and I hope you get to know Colombia
on a whole new level
[Music]